morph and manifest enjoyers rejoice as
these mechanics are back in Murders At
Carlo Mana but they look just a little
bit different literally let's go over
all the rules you need to know to take
full advantage of the two new mechanics
disguise and cloak let's start with
disguise disguise is a variant of the
morph ability for any card that has the
disguise keyword on it you may turn it
face down and cast it as a 2 two
creature with no name subtype or Mana
cost for just three generic Mana just
like a normal morph card however unlike
morph the disguised creature also has
Ward to meaning if it were to become a
target of a spell or an ability an
opponent controls while in play counter
that spell or ability unless they pay
two now one thing to keep in mind any
effects or prohibitions that would apply
to Casting a card with these
characteristics are applied to
disguising a card so for example if your
opponent controlled a void win you would
not be able to disguise any creatures
while disguised creatures don't have a
Mana value the rules state that the Mana
value of an object with no Mana cost is
zero and in Magic zero is considered
even so you literally can't even once
the disguised permanent is in play you
may turn it face up at any time by
simply revealing the card to your
opponent to show its disguise cost and
then pay that cost just like with morphs
turning a permanent face up this way is
considered to be a special action and it
doesn't use the stack most notably this
allows players to interact with cards
that have split second so in Commander
if your opponent cast something like
legless is quick reflexes you can turn
either a skin thinner face up to destroy
that creature or a void Mage Apprentice
to Simply counter the spell
here's one extra tricky rule to keep in
mind about morphed and disguised
creatures if someone enchants one of
your disguised creatures with a card
like eaten by piranhas you will not be
able to turn the disguised creature face
up this is because in this case eaten by
piranas has removed all abilities from
the card so when you turn the creature
face up to show your opponent its
disguise cost it won't have one because
it's lost all its ability
the same interaction applies when
attempting to turn branch of V2 gazi
face up while there is a blood moon in
play the front side of branch of V2 gazi
would be a mountain with no abilities so
there's no disguise cost to show and pay
moving on to our next mechanic we have
cloak cloak is extremely similar to
manifest however manifest always took
the top card of yours or your opponent's
library and put it onto the battlefield
as a face down 22 creature cloak can
happen from different zones depending on
what the card instructs you to do ITR
deadly futra can cloak the top card of
someone's Library whereas expose the
culprit lets you cloak face up creatures
you control the cloaked creatures are
treated just like disguised creatures
tutos with no name no Mana cost no
subtype and Ward to just like with
manifest if the cloak card is a creature
card you can turn it face up by paying
its Mana cost or if it has a disguise
cost you can pay that instead you cannot
turn non-creature cards face up unless
they have a disguise cost or are granted
a special ability like the one from
atrata also for both disguise and cloak
turning a card face up is not the same
as changing zones it's just like the
classic transform cards like Delver of
secrets so anything think enchanting it
equipped to it targeting it or the
counters on it remain the same unless of
course your creature is now suddenly a
tree branch any illegally attached auras
equipment and targeted spells will fall
off or fizzle of course the counters
would remain in this case now while
that's everything you need to know from
a mechanic's perspective there's a
couple of other rules about face down
cards that apply here too firstly with
multiple face down cards in play or on
the stack you must ensure that it's
clear to your opponents the order in
which these cards entered play you are
not allowed to mix up the cards to try
and confuse your opponents we're playing
Magic the Gathering not three card Monty
secondly if any face down spell leaves
the stack and goes to any other Zone
than the battlefield or if a face down
permanent moves to any Zone you must
reveal it you also must reveal any face
down permanence or spells you control if
you leave the game or when the game is
over now to wrap up the video here's a
secret rule that head designer for MTG
Mark rosewater mentioned in the murders
at carof Manor debut after show that
previously applied to morph cards will
also apply to disguise the five Mana
rule any disguised creature that would
destroy an opposing 2u in combat and
survive if it would be turned face up
will'll always have a disguise cost of
five or more that is to say if you
attacked your opponent with a grizzly
bear and they had a face down creature
with only four Manor available you can
be sure that if they blocked your tutu
even if that creature were to be turned
face up both creatures would end up
dying at the end of combat in a worst
case scenario assuming no other effects
or spells came into play
so be sure to keep this one in mind when
heading into standard and limited as
always if you learned something from
this video be sure to leave a like and
let me know in the comments down below
what you think of Disguise and cloak
subscribe if you know who done it and
I'll see you in the next one